have a look at this integral okay this
is a perfect example it was very very
well crafted
it's a perfect example of an integral
which because of its nature
can be approached in many different ways
i saw at least
six different ways three of them were
about
okay one of them was the best okay so
i'm going to show you i won't
i won't rehearse all the writing because
it'll take me forever um
but i will show you the important like
the the basic pathways
and where i awarded marks for each one
because everyone went different ways
okay so probably the most
the longest so the least efficient but
the
still okay method that i would count is
to do this by parts
okay you can do this by parts probably
the smartest way if you want to divide
this up
you think about what product is going to
be most useful to you
you want to recognize 10 squared you can
substitute that for
6 squared minus 1 right
a couple of you did one minus six quick
basic stuff right
if you always struggle with those just
come back to this guy
because evidently some of you do they
all come from here
right and the signs will they'll muck
you up right
usually if you got the for example if
instead of this
if you got this round the wrong way okay
and that was the only area that you made
you probably got two out of three if you
follow through anyway
okay now if i go with that you think
about okay what am i going to divide up
you can choose this right that's easy to
integrate because it's going to go there
that's also easy to work with okay so
you do this by parts where were the
three marks
number one was for the next line okay so
that was your uv minus um
vdu which looked like this
okay if you did it by parts here was one
mark
the second mark was for going through
and actually evaluating all of these
in other words you had to actually get
rid of all of your integrals
get it in terms of pies on six and pies
on threes and all that kind of thing
that was your second mark
your third mark was for getting past
that evaluation of the integral
right and then to actually simplify and
there was a variety of ways to put it
some of you stopped at let's see what
was a nice place to stop at
two root no sorry two one root three
plus root three on two minus two a lot
of you stopped there and that was
acceptable i suppose would have been
nicer to rationalize you would have got
something like this
or maybe minus 12 all over six
okay so let me just repeat that one mark
for your actual integration by parts
you don't get any mark just for doing a
trig identity that's
not an extension two type of thing that
i'm assessing okay
in this question one mark here another
mark for the evaluation of all those
integrals
and then your final mark for actually
simplifying all that evaluation
okay but and this is why i skipped it
when you do it by part
you get you've got like eight terms to
evaluate right so that's what i mean by
it's a very inefficient way
so by the time you got to question four
you just ran out of time or you looked
at question three and you thought forget
that
i got no time to mess with that because
i've already spent so much time on this
question
right so doing all my parts not the best
way
what's a better way i've lost track of
my pieces of paper
hold on oh there it is uh
a better way was choosing a substitution
up here okay so instead of going to this
line
and um using your pythagorean identity
to expand out
you might have gone straight from this
line and said well
okay tan squared that's sine squared on
cos squared
right
so really what i've got is sine cubed
on cos squared okay yes
so at this point a lot of you saw okay i
can choose a um
i can choose a substitution here that
will work for me
namely
cos x that's almost certainly what you
chose okay
so once you do that you get your du on
dx which is negative sign
if you're doing a substitution of course
you have to change the boundaries
right so there was the first mark you
see it's a completely different pathway
right
so the first one for us for getting this
part
um oops sorry x equals this
x equals this you're going to get two
values of u
right so if you did it by substitution
you've got your first mark for all this
right um you've got your second mark for
once you did your substitution and this
is the reason why it's better than doing
it by parts
all you end up having to integrate is
this
that's wrong sorry
right so that was really really easy so
you got no marks by just getting to that
point after the substitution
you got the mark for doing the integral
right now
a lot of you did this by substitution
which was good better call that
integration by parts
however you got twisted in here right
and you got very very close
but you got confused with the fact that
this is u to the minus
two minus two right so your actual
integral of this
is this
okay so the number of variations i saw
on people who
either had a minus sign out in front or
had a minus sign in here
or had it flipped around and a minus
sign lots and lots of those kinds of
errors
okay so maybe at this point if you saw
you got to here
and then you mucked up the next step
maybe what you need to do is be more
careful and take more time
and say look that's this right
and then make sure you get the primitive
of u to the minus two correct
see these double negatives right they're
a recipe for disaster when you're in a
rush
so that's why those are the kinds of
things that you've got to take more care
with does that make sense
okay so after you got there you
integrated that was my
that was the second mark number one
number two and your third mark was for
getting to the same point
okay all right now we did it by parts we
did it by substitution
uh there was an even better way an even
faster way
and some of you will be like oh i can't
believe i could have done it so quickly
let's have a look at it this way the
reason why it's um
it's quicker is because it's one of
those where you sort of have to
see one of those trig identities and if
you don't see it then you're left to go
to one of these other methods okay
so you started here right actually even
if you did this line
okay so you get to sec squared right
ah but have a look at this if you
combine these two
have a look at those right that's sine
on cos squared
right those two together sine on cos
squared
so really what that is is
sine one cos squared is sectan isn't it
sectan there's the sign on cos and
there's the one on close
that's sine squared on cos there it is
right but sec tan that's an integral
you're
sorry that's a you know the primitives
of this that's a known result
right and then of course you've got a
minus sign
off on the end right so if you saw this
and i think maybe
one of you did right um you get this
very very simple
integral bam
right no substitution very very simple
result
not like 50 million things you need to
evaluate and so that's what saves you
time
you get to the same answer right so that
was the the quickest way
right but it took a lot of mental effort
i think to see that and realize
ah okay that's going to be a good way to
go
just as a point of interest i think the
reason that the thing that would
separate people
um who recognize this and people who
went other methods
is that they know this is a useful
result right
so as they know their primitives well
okay so
you can see how useful it is like we
hate memorizing things right
but memorizing saves you time because it
helps you recognize things
especially in the heat of the moment